[Music]
simon what's new not much man yeah good
i like your new hairstyle yeah
your publicist didn't tell you this was
happening
you thought you were going to come by do
a normal talk show interview yeah yeah
and then this [ __ ] broke out yeah crazy
and he left his coat on so he can make a
break for it
out of here so fast you look like a news
anchor that's taking some peyote in
cancun or something
that actually is the feeling i have
right now uh it's not is it is the color
uh natural up close yeah it's really
really uh
like carrot orangey yeah
yeah it's very it's a very unnatural
color but i might stick with it it's
good yeah i'm glad you like it i will
stick with it and thank you for being
here
uh let's talk about uh australia your
native australia do you get back there
much i go i go twice a year
nice yeah do you uh what i've always
loved about australia is you guys it
seems like your television is
particularly uninhibited
you know it feels like you guys just cut
loose on television like our award shows
you know our emmys our oscars it seems
like they're kind of a little stiff when
you guys have an award show it really
gets kind of crazy well
you know
it's a party yeah
and uh that's the way they approach it
first and foremost in australia over
here it's sort of you know it's business
and it's for the broadcast right you
know you go to an ad every five minutes
if you did that in australia everyone
would be there'd be no one left in the
audience because everyone goes to the
bar but people
embrace the idea that there's a bit of
free booze and you know time to slap
each other on the back and that's the
key thing is there's a lot of drinking
at the award shows in australia there is
because they kind of try and i think
except for the golden globes like here
it feels like yeah there's no you can't
get to the bar there's no they don't
encourage alcohol no they don't like it
when you leave your seat really right
because then they've got to put a seat
filler in right but no in australia yeah
people get uh my first award show in
australia was called was the logies and
it was i was like 22 or something and
tom jones was a special guest
uh star yeah and of course he's saying
uh
it's not unusual
it's not unusual to be loved
how about this he had cue cards
that's his biggest song ever yeah
and he had cue cards that's like bruce
springsteen and a singing and a guy
holding a card that says born in usa
yeah
oh yeah flip it
he had cue cards and he um i also caught
him he was kind of he was making eyes at
my wife
tom john well of course he that's what
he does yeah
he was you'd be disappointed if he
wasn't doing that sort of it was a
little bit like
really dude yeah
i think with tom jones it's yes really
yeah